welcome back to the which mentions a
goodbye tessitura last night one of the
NFL season we saw Jackson 5 touchdown
performance with his arm on and week one
in Miami and then last night 15 at 20
169 pass yards five touchdowns no picks
a passer rating just shy of a hundred
and forty eight carries of his own 495
yards that is what we call living your
best life and he is the Capital One best
life player of the week period end of
story barn on capital on his reimagined
banking by offering savings and checking
accounts with no fees or minimums when
the nation's best savings rate Capital
One what's in your wallet the only other
player in the history the NFL to throw
for five touchdowns and also rushed for
90 yards or more in that singing single
game was Cam Newton week 15 2015 against
the Giants he was your unanimous
selection for most valuable player that
year as his team won the conference went
to the Super Bowl eventually only to
lose in Peyton Manning's farewell game
with the Denver Broncos man who called
the game last night locally for the Rams
radio network my colleague from the NFL
media group as well one of my good
friends Maurice jones-drew good to see
you here on the show he does he is well
written
what in the heck was that like seen in
person uh it was you know it was crazy
because it wasn't like he was just
running all over the place and I think
when you think of Lamar Jackson and the
Baltimore Ravens you think like it's
gonna be a lot of rich zone reads and
he's gonna take off that wasn't the case
I mean literally they were so efficient
from the first play of the game to the
last play they were averaging I want to
say at one point almost nine yards to
carry if not more and it's because you
have to you have to be concerned about
Lamar Jackson so you're always taking a
guy out of the play and then they have
some great running backs our offensive
line was playing really well and then
when they decided to throw the ball
because you're so concerned about
Lamar's running ability guys are just
running open and I mean he was Dillon
last night so it was it was it was
impressive to see I mean efficient
is a a great word to use and and it's
it's not the usual word that you would
use for team that's just one forty five
to six right right you could call
dominant you could call super you could
call all different adjectives but
efficient is perfect this stat says it
all every rush that they had last night
was four positive yards yeah every
removing the three rg3 kneel downs right
every time somebody took off running the
ball for the Ravens last night there was
positive yards and it's not like there's
no slouch on that defensive line for the
Rams mr. tackle for loss himself as
Aaron Donald out there every single
touch was efficient they made he
efficient use of every play last night
well for me it was it's their offensive
line doesn't get enough credit I mean
they lost their Center maybe in the
first quarter ish and we were kind of in
the broadcast myself and JB long were
like well maybe this may be the
opportunity that we can go and have an
undrafted kid you rookie out of Cal
Berkeley who's gonna come in and it was
like nothing ever had nothing happening
I mean they were just breaking off runs
left and right and so they they they did
a phenomenal job you know I was talking
with Coach McVeigh after the game I was
just like credit to them like they did a
great job both offensively defense
internal special teams and there's a
stat that JB had said JB long has said
during the game that Baltimore they get
first downs on first and second down
they rarely get it on third down and
then when they do if they don't get it
on third then they go for it on fourth
down every time pretty much and I mean
think it was a fourth and four late in
the third quarter right and they went
for and they got it well I mean they
started a punt and then they brought
Tucker on the field yeah and then Lamar
waived him all off I got this and that
was what led to the Willie Snead score
to make it to Jackson five and then
finally wrapped up his night last night
so when it comes down to it and again I
I say this fully knowing I've got
Michael Vick coming on and our three
have you ever seen anything like Lamar
Jackson so I have to tell you this story
before I had like dive into that we had
heard and when I was in Jax what about
this kid in Orlando
and what he was kind of doing so we
drove down to see him play what do you
mean uh in high school when he was in
high school you just hear like all the
stories about all the kids when you're
at the jacks Jeff yeah so Derek Henry
was right up the street at you Lee we
drove down to see Lamar played and we it
wasn't it like sat almost to the side
just and he was spectacular then
watching my Louisville he spectacular
there so you know when I was always
hearing all this stuff like hey this guy
should play receiver like that's all
he's ever played was quarterback his
whole life he's never played anything
else you just have to commit to his
skill set and what Baltimore did this
offseason where they went to Louisville
they talked to all the coaches they
figure out what he did well what he
didn't do well and they've really
created a offensive scheme around that I
wasn't surprised they went to the
playoffs last year when he finally got
in what I am surprised is that his
ability to throw the ball when he
scrambles so we always see Russell
Wilson scramble and he'll always looking
downfield
that's what Lamar does now before he
would just take off normally so they've
changed his game a little bit but I've
never seen anything - the fact we're
like they're they dance after every
incompletion every good play they're
having a great time they're smiling you
know he just has this energy about him
that it's weird like I've never seen
like Marlon Humphrey batted a ball down
maybe in the fourth quarter this goes to
his why he's so good and Lamar Jackson
is the first one up there cheering
Humphrey on like talking trash to him
like I can't believe they tried you and
then here comes Mark Ingram here good
like and then all everyone starts
feeding off that then they you know so
his energy is infectious and the way he
plays they all play for him he's helping
linemen up off the ground I mean he's
throwing blocks when he needs to
he just loves a game of football and
it's great to see an organization really
I'm trying to get the word really just
commit to what he is and say we're not
gonna change you to be this pocket
passer like we've seen the Carolina
Panthers do - Cam Newton like no we're
gonna make we this is who you are and
we're gonna continue to build around you
I mean John Harbaugh this year raved the
Ravens caught him sitting down with yes
Lamar I think it was in sin sin
after his spinorama and he went for six
and he basically said you know you're
gonna have the kids are gonna be wearing
number eight you're that special and and
I from that I picked up what a little
bit of what you just said they've
embraced right they've committed they
went in he was on the hot seat last year
John and he had the ability and the
foresight and the intelligence and the
gumption to basically say I've got my
quarterback that I've won a Super Bowl
with right Ozzie Newsome left this under
the tree before he left
right under the football Christmas tree
and I'm gonna open that present right
now and we're gonna midseason switch
things up so that embrace what you would
I heard him basically say that to him
was just verbally adding on to the
embrace but on top of it that he's
doesn't have an ego that the coach would
be concerned about feeding by saying him
you know what you're special I thought
that just told so much as to why he is
in a way some some body and some being
essence that we just haven't seen well
last night before the game
the Rams had Watts Rams they're one of
their youth organizations that they they
football youth football organization
that they work with and Lamar goes up at
high fives
every kid down the line now mind this is
when you're warming up and you know some
people take that warm up like I always
try to get into the zone and so I try to
like clear everything out when they were
just as losses can be like I mean he has
this is his all off the field stuff like
you see him in videos with his teammates
like they're always smiling everyone's
having a good time when you talk to
their coaches all they say is he's
humble he's humble about it it's not
like he's like look at me look at me
he's always trying to put the attention
on someone else and so they I mean again
this is a team that is young and scary
because you know that I never understood
that is like they're too young to know
what they're doing but I see it now
right like they're just out there having
a great time they're just playing
football like it's in the backyard and
what they do travels well so it's gonna
be exciting to see kind of
you know this next matchup against the
Niners how there's O's and then down the
road I mean they they punked the the no
Patriots they punked the Texans the
Seahawks they punked
the Rams last night they're hard to
think that the Niners aren't gonna be
next
you know no I'm talking about a ten and
one team with a front seven that is
particularly frightening and may be
quick enough to be able to handle all of
the motion and fakes and movements and
handle the punishment that might come if
you're peripherally of following
something that's a Fugazi and then
you're getting hit in the face that
they'd be able to handle that well I'll
say this and I rarely try to talk
positive about the night except we're
Bellator school right so you have to
pick a side but sure um
they they're the Niners are equipped to
handle it they have enough guys on the
front line that they're big enough
strong enough and they're linebackers
are fast enough to run sideline the
sideline
the key is you just can't have any eye
violations or miss Reed's or my steps if
you get those I mean oh and I'm watching
the Rams like they switch their whole
diva they went to like a a 6-2 defense
where they had six down linemen two
linebackers or a six one trying to
figure things out and they still
couldn't do it so it's gonna be an
interesting matchup but I can't wait to
see I know Kyle Shanahan is gonna have
some offensively for them but again like
it's just one of those situations where
this team is there they believe that
they're good and they're playing at such
a high level and I say efficient and you
talk about the no negative run plays
there was plays where they'd the Rams
that stopped them there we were cheering
on and it was six yard games but that's
not a that's not something you cheer for
you know guys are breaking off 18 2016
yard gains left and right and so you're
cheering for a six yard positive gain
that that's when it was started to get
demoralizing ah demoralizing and again
just to wrap up the efficiency 15
completions a third of them four
touchdowns I mean it's just crazy
169 passing yards that's it nobody still
five touchdowns in 90 rush yards and a
in your left in and a pile of dust I
mean that's what they're doing
right now I mean when it was 35 6 I'll
probably let off the gas a little no no
well I mean that's the hardball
yeah that's the what you know what's
your deal bro yeah I mean that's in the
DNA no question Maurice jones-drew here
on the Rich Eisen show I want to hit you
on some rams conventional wisdom yeah I
got job we were just talking about how
the Ravens offense and it's tough to
figure out
has the league figured out the Shaun
mctavey Rams offense EIII I truly don't
I can't say if they have they have it I
feel like last the last couple years
you've had the same five offensive
linemen playing and as we saw in
Baltimore their offensive line is really
good where the Rams have shuffled guys
left and right you're playing guys that
have never started before you're playing
rookies you're playing guys who've
played maybe two or three games at
certain positions then you have Andrew
Whitworth there right like everyone else
is brand-new pretty much and so when
they were really good their offensive
line was one of the top in the league
right now obviously their offensive line
is not there and so regardless of when
you're calling plays and I always try to
this what I was kind of trying to do
when everyone was like you know the
genius and any Greta coach me buddy came
in and changed it our organization like
that which is it was very tough to do
but it's the players on the field that
have to execute your game plan you have
to have those players that have the
ability to execute it as well so I feel
like a lot of the issues that they're
having now is like a lot of pressure
from the inside which they didn't have
much pressure yesterday but you know the
Baltimore Ravens defense really you know
they exposed a lot of what some of the
rams faults were you know it's running
the same plays over and over again being
able to diagnose um in certain
situations what Marcus Peters got his
first pick that's why I'm asking if it's
been figured out I mean it's been two
years since McVeigh came on the scene
Belichick last year gave potentially a
blueprint for everybody to see although
it's tough to execute what fellow check
has because you don't have the players
don't have the day-in day-out snap and
snap out practice mentality potentially
or or or I guess that that coach who's
running it that's why I'm asking I mean
because it's the line is banged up a
thousand percent but that's still number
30 that's still cup and
yeah and cooks who just came back last
night
same tight ends right it's just it's
lost right now and golf looks totally
completely different right different
yeah I'll say this you know everyone has
tendencies and that's kind of the part
of the NFL where you have self scouting
so teams have two years of your
tendencies and what you like to do on
certain in certain situations and I
think that's where they figured out if
you look at the Pittsburgh Steelers game
they knew on third down third in certain
situations that they're gonna try to get
the ball to Cooper Cup so we're gonna
double-team one with Minka Fitzpatrick
anywhere he goes there's other games
where like you're facing the Niners and
you have opportunities to go down and
probably take the game over and possibly
win the game you stopped on fourth down
you come out of the half and you fumble
the first carry right so they've had
some some unfortunate situations go
around but even when they have big plays
and this is what is concerning with me
even when they have big plays and you
want to get excited there's always
something that brings a big play back so
they can't get into that rhythm that
they've been in you know when you look
at some of the games they've had over
the last couple years they'll get into a
rhythm I started no huddle they'll start
getting actually taking shots different
things and it opens up now when they try
to get in that rhythm something I was
always pulling them back so it may be
teams to figure it out it may be that
they just have gotten old in certain
situations or they're just brand new in
certain situations and it's you know it
may be I think it's a nice gumbo pot of
a little bit of everything in a way
mm-hmm what do you think they're gonna
do in the off season with no first-round
draft choices but again they're you
still have a kid who was a Super Bowl
quarterback west last year right at some
point we are gonna see the girlie of the
first 12 weeks of last year again right
yeah I think so I mean I thought he ran
well against Pittsburgh I thought he ran
well against Chicago against that
defense has been pretty tough it's just
you can't have six carries and they
expect Gurley to go for a hundred and
two hundred yards that's not gonna
happen and so you have to feed him more
you have to want or at least try to be
in a position to feed him more all right
you get down 40 no real quick against
the Baltimore Ravens every play car is
going to go
throwing the ball so III personally feel
like and I've said this all year like
they had a plan about utilizing Todd
Gurley this season but once you start
losing that plan has to go out the
window you just have to try to find ways
to win games and and 30 is your best way
to win games because when he's running
well as you saw against the Chicago
Bears
they were running well and then all of a
sudden guys are running wide open on the
play-action pass right and so that's
what it was the first two years Todd
would get these runs he started breaking
these runs off and then all of a sudden
you pull it out and then you you throw
the ball down the field Robert Woods is
by yourself for people caused by
yourself like second level to all right
not not like quick pass exactly so you
you have to find a way to get to get
back to that and going forward it's it's
so yeah they got demolished last night
forty five to six it was you know
disheartening but this is the funny
thing about it it was AFC opponent and
really didn't have much to do with the
stand no it's true it you're right it's
an AFC opponent and it's just it's a
loss yeah it's just bounce and so you
have the next five opponents or NFC yeah
and you can if you can find a way to run
the table you have a chance to make make
it to the playoffs and so yeah that's
gonna take 11 wins though it's gonna
definitely take a level if the way
Minnesota is playing in Seattle and you
get to play Seattle at home so that's
nice in Minnesota in Minnesota in
Seattle play this week coming up so you
have a chance to get back in this race
you just have to you can't you can't
there's no slipping up anymore last one
for you Maurice what happened with the
speaking of gumbo Marcus Peters and
Jalen after the game last night
yes it was actually they were chirping
the whole time and that's you know both
of them are very chirpy yeah they're
chirpy you know they're they're alpha
males they they consider themselves to
be the best great I think they're both
top competitors like I've got an
altercation with people when I played
even guys that I know just because we
just you just talking and it kind of
bullet boils over like granted Jalen was
up said they lost 45 to 6 and Marcus
Peter says everyone's smiling and
hugging Marcus was like hey great job
man you know he's upset I think it was
just like this kind of that boiling over
I don't think anything would have
happened though and last one for you
Weddell not coughing up some of the
ravens
secrets or potential game plan is that
cool I mean I know everyone's cool with
him just as a guy and as a teammate but
now post 45 six here
I think there with well so I you know
you you said there are certain times I
remember playing and we traded a guy to
the Detroit Lions and Mike Thomas and we
play on the next we got was hurt and
he's literally with the defensive
coordinator telling them every play that
we're checking to because you gonna hear
it but that to me was like are you gone
too far but again I understand why
you're doing it you're a little upset
that you had traded like you know I
think for Eric Waddell it shows his
appreciation for that organization what
they did for him is that he's not gonna
do that and I think I don't know if
Marcus Peters did it or if he didn't do
it but you know he did you know he did I
mean because because he's probably
pissed that he got yeah that he was
viewed as just yeah we just got to get
rid of it because we need to make room
for Jalen right no and you know what and
and if he did was he probably did it's
part of the game like that's that's
that's what happens when you trade
people and they they get upset like but
what if Weddell you don't think there's
anybody in that lock I don't think I
don't think if what Oh even if he said
anything it wasn't gonna change because
that's how dominant it was man if you
don't know it's the weather part is
Lamar Jackson ever around a 40 so no one
knows exactly how fast he is right like
so when you do these scouting reports
you're gonna say like he's fast but no
one knows what how fast like is it for
three is if for four is it for two so
you don't know the angles that you need
to take to get there
you got Weddell from last night can you
cue that up before we send Maurice
jones-drew away here or I know we we'd
listen to it before the show because did
you I mean cuz you know and the reason
why Lamar did not work out at the
combine like that was because everyone
was trying to still at that point
crazy talk about maybe you should work
out at wide receiver or something like
some scouts were thinking like hey can
you do that and you didn't want to give
that any oxygen at all so you didn't
even run at the combine here's a Weddell
after the game there's nothing like it
you can't emulate it how are you gonna
practice it well Mars the fastest got on
the field and now you got I was sent a
little frustrated don't take it it's
just he's he's an MVP for a reason how
fast do you think he is is he wouldíve
run a 4-3 for sure easily he bases in
pads man what we're seeing yeah like
don't don't be surprised if he's as fast
as Hollywood Brown like that's that's
how fast he is and I mean you have to
and it's different like I said I've seen
him at all three levels from high school
to the to the pros and it hasn't changed
like he is an animal and his mom
supports that his dream is to play
quarterback I remember there's a story
coming out of Louisville that they had
him like try to return punts and his mom
had to call the coach was like hey like
this is not what we agree it's not what
we agreed upon you heard that sir right
this is not what we were doing and so
she knew and so I think you know him not
run in the 40 them really being totally
committed to it in the scouting report
that you get on him it'll never tell you
a speed like I would just put four one
on there they said look is what he so
you know you better take the correct
angle you better over correct yourself
to try to go get him yeah Hollywood were
Brown ran a 4-3 at his pro day and
that's when he was coming back from a
foot injury to we might just need to see
them just kind of like handoff to him on
a jet motion or something like that and
and then he just and Lamar just got to
pull a Tyreke Hill as Hollywood Browns
go right on the hill just run past him
like he did the damage that would happen
to me rich ice I think I'd have been
more upset than solder be like yo get
away from me walked up and caught me
being your dog and laughing mjd on
Twitter at em period at jones-drew 32 on
Instagram check this man out on
Thanksgiving night on NFL Total Access
after the Cowboys games or prior to the
cowboy game and in between cowboys and
Saints Falcons maybe at the very end to
depending that someone may get snowed in
its snowed in yeah question California
there you go this man Maurice jones-drew
hard work hard working man you're great
brother thanks for coming in here that's
Maurice jones-drew on the Rich Eisen
show from Laura
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app